6 27 on your wednesday morning how about
a pat on the back and an attaboy to the
nevada department of transportation you
know when
mom nature shut down the main road
between clark and lincoln counties a
week ago tonight boy
it was not a pretty picture
indot spells it out this way torrential
rain
and mudslides across u.s 93 left a
10 foot tall 30 foot wide
earthen deposit about 15 miles south of
alamo
the equivalent of almost three football
fields laid
end to end two dozen workers used
six front wheel loaders nine tractor
trailers
and a bulldozer it took him
six hundred truck trips to move over
seventeen
thousand cubic yards of material
national weather service estimating
upwards of two and a half inches of rain
fell in that area in a 48-hour period
that led to the approximately 36-hour
detour for drivers
into southwest utah to get back into
lincoln county kudos again to the
emergency response contractor
aggregate industries as well as all the
n-dot crews who made it happen
now there will not be a quiz on any of
this but you can go back over all the
facts and figures or better yet
share it with your friends on the social
medias by going to the link for this and
all our stories on our website
8newsnow.com click traffic then driving
me crazy buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8
8 news now dot com